hello everyone
i'm aj numa the producer of the legend
of zelda series
we mentioned in the june 2019 nintendo
direct presentation that we had started
development on the sequel to the legend
of zelda breath of the wild
many people around the world are still
playing breath of the wild
so i'd like to thank you all from the
bottom of my heart everyone
thank you so much
regarding the sequel in order to make
the vast world you enjoyed exploring in
the original game even more impressive
the team is working hard on its
development so you'll have to wait a bit
longer before we can provide more
updates
in the meantime we've prepared a
different way for you to experience the
world of hyrule
and we have a video to introduce it
please take a look
the history of the royal family of
hyrule
is also the history of calamity gammon
a primal evil that has endured over the
ages
i think you are now ready ready to hear
what happened
100 years ago
[Music]
[Music]
what
this game takes place 100 years before
the events of the legend of zelda breath
of the wild
the great calamity that occurred 100
years prior was mentioned
but the actual event itself wasn't shown
in full
in this game you'll be able to
experience the events of the great
calamity
so now i would like to invite kawai
tecmo games producer mr hayashi
to join me here
tecmo games and the producer of this
game hyrule warriors age of calamity
began when mr aonuma approached us
saying i think it would be interesting
to create a warriors game telling the
story of the great calamity
what do you think the battles between
the kingdom of hyrule and calamity
gannon
would complement warrior-style gameplay
against large armies
[Music]
the previous hyrule warriors games were
filled with zelda conventions
the legend of zelda breath of the wild
broke these conventions entirely
and perhaps it's the same for everyone
here but for someone like me
who's been playing zelda games for a
long time this was an extraordinary
experience
it's a new special title for me
unlike the previous hyrule warriors
games hyrule warriors age of calamity
was developed by working closely with
the zelda team in every step of the
process
including gameplay direction graphics
world
and all dialogue and while we maintain
the distinct gameplay style of the
warriors series
with exciting one versus one thousand
battles and a wide variety
of playable characters this became the
only game that will let you experience
the world
100 years prior to the events of the
legend of zelda
breath of the wild first hand
during the development of the previous
hyrule warriors games i was impressed
with how the warriors development team
led by mr hayashi had a deep
understanding of the legend of zelda
series
this time around they made it possible
to create this new experience by
combining the well-detailed world
of breath of the wild with warriors
gameplay therefore i believe this game
will offer the experience of the great
calamity battles that weren't fully
shown in the original game
i hope that both those who played the
previous hyrule warriors games
and those who played the legend of zelda
breath of the wild can experience this
game
hyrule warriors age of calamity will
launch
on november 20th
[Music]
thank you for your continued support for
the legend of zelda and this game
was